vous avez été fait
pour être gouverné
à la fin
ce sera chacun pour soi
que faisons-nous
nous nous préparons
il y avait une idée
de réunir
un groupe de personnes remarquables
afin que lorsque nous en avions besoin,
ils puissent mener les batailles
que nous ne pourrions jamais
messieurs
qu'est-ce que tu es prêt à faire
sans offense mais je ne joue pas bien avec les
autres grand homme en armure
enlève ça qu'est-ce que tu es euh génie
milliardaire playboy philanthrope
si nous ne pouvons pas protéger la terre
tu peux être sacrément sûr que nous '  Je vais le venger
dr banner votre travail est sans précédent et
je suis un grand fan de la façon dont vous perdez le
contrôle et vous transformez en un énorme
monstre de rage verte
merci